in may melinda french gates received
more than three billion dollars in stock
from her soon-to-be ex-husband bill
gates
making her a billionaire today worth 3.2
billion dollars
she received 851 million dollars worth
of shares and farm equipment maker
deerinko
according to sec filings she also
received 2.4 billion dollars worth of
stock
in four other companies canadian
national railway
car dealership group autonation mexican
coke bottler coca-cola femsa
and mexican broadcaster grupo televisa
bill
remains the fourth richest person in the
world with an estimated net worth of
126.6 billion dollars
as for melinda it remains unclear how
much of the fortune she will end up with
following the divorce
the pair asked a judge in washington to
follow a separation agreement
a contract signed when spouses are
living apart but have not yet divorced
the terms of the contract have not been
disclosed so it is not yet known who
will get their main family residence a
131 million dollar estate dubbed zandu
2.0
along with their other homes private
planes and large farmland holdings
while details of the split haven't been
confirmed by the pair according to the
wall street journal melinda began
consulting divorce lawyers as far back
as 2019
after bill's meetings with deceased
sexual predator jeffrey epstein came to
light
also according to the wall street
journal a spokesperson for bill admitted
he had an
affair with a microsoft employee in 2000
which the company's board
investigated in 2019 bill stepped down
for microsoft's board before the probe
was completed
though the spokesperson denies he did so
because of the investigation